- Okay.
Got to share with you my 15
years of living on Skid Row,
downtown L.A., Skid Row.
And this place it's just way out.
You got so many resources,
but you got so many people
that just don't want it.
They've gotten too comfortable
with being on Skid Row
and it's like this is
the life that they chose,
a life that I have chose.
You often choose this life
when you feel hopeless.
And not only that it's
like, it could be a rush.
It can be a challenge.
It can be really pretty much
whatever you want it to be.
You decide your own fate on Skid Row.
You can be in the wrong
places at the wrong time.
You can not be an addict and
become an addict overnight.
I mean, it's just a little bit
of everything that goes on.
You know?
I support myself on Skid Row by,
I like to say performing sexual favors.
That's like a better way
of wording, prostituting or hoeing.
I perform sexual favors.
This go around, it's been around
where I cannot say that
I have used condoms
because it's like, this go around.
I have to go harder in the pain.
It's like, this is nothing like it was,
I'll say eight years ago when
I was down here on Skid Row.
And now that I'm back on Skid Row,
it's like it's almost
keeping up with technology.
It's like, it is, ah.
What's the word I'm looking for?
It is, what's that word
type of advancing, you know?
So it's like the price
of drugs have went up.
The price of pussy went
down, excuse my language.
And it's like, you could
pretty much sell anybody
and everything on Skid Row.
You know, everything is for sale.
Every one's for sale.
And it's like, it's deep.
It's really, really deep.
And believe it or not,
these are people's lives here on Skid Row.
This is their hometown.
They literally, they'll bash your head in.
You know, if they don't know you
and you're walking certain
blocks on Skid Row, you know,
part of it's a paranoia
of you being a police
or snitch or an informant.
And part of it is somebody that's about
to retaliate on them.
So, I mean, it's just like that saying
where they said this is
the devil's playground.
Well, it truly is.
I'm starting to do things
that I said I would never do.
And it's mentally bothering me, you know,
but it is what it is.
I, like I said, I'm starting to do things
that I said I would never do.
And it's like, it's
nowhere a value leaning.
It's not even worth it.
You know, because at the
end of the day, like I said,
I'm supporting myself
by working the streets.
I don't sell drugs.
I don't panhandle, you know,
I just use what I've got.
You know, I wanna say my mom's gift
and God's gift, you know?
So just never say you'll do
something until that time comes.
Basically.
That's my advice to you
because when your back is
to the wall, you never
know what you'll do.
And it's kind of exciting
because it's like, for me,
I know this is not my life.
So for the people that are
on the outside looking in,
it's like, you could think
what you want to think about me
because again, I know
that this is not my life.
I know what I'm achieving
and how I'm trying
to get out of Skid Row before
being kicked out of Skid Row.
Believe it or not,
you can literally be
kicked out of Skid Row.
You could be ran out of Skate Row.
You can be forced out of Skid Row.
And it's like, what the hell?
You know?
But it's some for real, for real stuff.
So before any of that
should happen, you know,
I'm taking steps
to get out of Skid Row
peacefully, hopefully.
And you know, in my right
state of mind, you know,
I had a couple of good
friends that we used to grind
or hustle as some people call it together
and they got caught up in the mix.
And it's just like, you gotta
watch who you hang with,
who you roll with, who
you smoke with, you know,
because it's like,
if you're with somebody
and they're known to do foul
shit and they do foul shit,
boom, bam, bam.
If you're with them, when your
smell, when they're smoking,
when they're doing whatever, I mean,
you're gonna reap the consequences
that they reap just as well because,
and someone else's mind is like,
either you had something to do with it,
either you knew about it.
So it's just so easy to get
caught up in the rapture
and the bullshit and the drama out here.
Skid Row is nothing but
drama and bullshit you know,
it's man, it's just misery
if you like company.
So it's like, I'm
literally like, like fed up
with getting loaded because
the dope isn't shit, you know,
it for one thing, it's
not what it used to be.
I know it's nowhere near what
it used to be in the eighties,
but then when you take
it back to the nineties,
it's like half of that.
So it's like, before I
blow my money off on that
that I have to go and,
you know, like I said,
perform sexual favors or whatever.
I'd rather get on my knees
and shoot dice and try to
turn my money over that way.
Or I rather eat it all up.
And, you know, so it's like,
you really gotta be strong minded
to be on Skid Row,
to make it through Skid
Row, to be able to sit here,
like I am right now talking to you.
I find myself performing
sexual favors in alleys.
And it's like, man,
who's to say I'm going to
make it out of that alley?
You know, who's to say
that this guy isn't going
to flip in the midst of,
if we're getting hired 9 times out of 10,
I try not to let it be that route.
But sometimes when I need
things such as not drugs,
but such as food money to do my laundry.
Cause there are no like
resources for free laundry.
They give you food.
But lately the food's been
making a lot of people sick.
I mean, a lot of people are OD'ing
on the particular drug that I do
which is crack cocaine.
And it's like, dealers are
so greedy and so thirsty.
They rather melt down a pill
and whip it up with something
rather than to go out
and purchase at least half
of, I mean, I smoke dope.
If I can afford $80 worth of dope,
I know they can.
You know,
but it's just, it's exciting.
It's not scary.
Cause I really fear no man but God,
but it's just something
to just really reflect on.
You know, you have to be
careful who your suppliers are,
you have to be careful of who
you accept free drugs from.
I mean, one of the things
that I've done this go around
that I said I'd never do was
to perform sexual favors for drugs.
And I found myself doing that
a few times this go around
for the simple fact, dealers
are out trying to make money.
They're not trying to spend money.
And it's like, if they get, you know,
get off with giving up a few
devs, then they'll do it.
But then the cold thing about it,
they switch up on,
you know, give you maybe
two rocks that's you know?
Okay.
And then the rest
of the shit will be straight bullshit.
So it's like, I guess that's what I give
for going against the grain.
And that was one of my rules
was not performing, you know,
sexual favors for drugs.
But I found myself kind
of being desperate.
It was enough that I could
trade off for a few things.
Cause you get some people down here.
Their hustle is to, they got somewhere
where they get fast food
and it's like they sell it
for a little bit of nothing
for the drugs.
So I found myself being desperate,
like I said, and it was,
you know, enough drugs that
I could smoke and, you know,
kind of live off.
But boy did I have a lot
of mad people, you know?
And it's just like, even
though it wasn't my fault,
still just that easy
how I got caught up in the rapture,
you know, not even knowing, you know,
so here it is, I'm sitting,
I'm smoking on, you know,
rocks that I feel came off the same rock
when literally it was,
you know, half and half,
bullshit and real.
So I noticed specifically
one that when this guy said,
you know, I'm like, dude,
I really don't feel comfortable doing that
because I don't know how your product is.
So I remember him specifically
shuffling them around
and eyeballing them
to where he knew what he was looking for.
But I didn't.
So the tester that they gave
me was just like, whoa, okay.
It took me there.
I'm like okay,
let's do this.
Let's you know, so
and then I'll say I continue
smoking off that same one.
And then I kind of, you know,
traded off a few pieces,
which was not off the one I was smoking.
So I had so many angry people
coming back to me saying,
"Hey I want my shit back.
You know, this shit is not, it's not real.
It's burning up.
It's choking me."
I'm like, "Bro, I'm smoking
off the same thing."
It was like, hold up, swell up.
And my mind I'm like, wow.
He did give me a couple of pieces.
So here it is, this honest
person all the time,
I'm finding myself somewhat
fibby and I'm not a liar
because you know, my mom always
said, if you tell one lie,
you have to tell another, you
have to remember the other.
So I'm getting into a lot of altercations
and I mean I'm fighting a
lot and I'm 42 years old.
I'm getting too old for this shit.
Yes.
I was addicted to getting the money
because the money was lovely back then.
And it was just like guys pay well.
And it was not even a 10 minute job.
I mean, I remember guys
getting to our rooms
and it will be over within
20 minutes and it's like, oh,
you could stay in a room.
But then that became a problem
because the motels stopped
letting the women stay
because of chaos.
So it was, it was kind of
lovely back then, you know?
It was fun back then,
getting with all the
women, us getting dressed
and getting ready to go,
you know, do our thing.
Because during the daytime
though, the guys that was
in our circle, some boosts, some you know,
did whatever it was they did.
And they would, you know,
look out for us until nightfall came.
Night fall was time for
the girls to get out there,
but we would all meet up at daybreak.
You know, like everybody had money.
Everybody had dope.
Everybody had something new
or they might've thought
about somebody who got somebody new.
Nowadays you can't even get
a bottle of water from nobody
and they want to hit
or they want a dollar.
And I'm mean, it's like, wow.
Jane will keep you from moving on.
It'll stagnate you.
So it's like, if you're
going to feel ashamed
about anything that you're
doing, that my advice
to you is not to do it because
shame will stagnate you.
Shame will make you feel some type
of way to where you can't even process
to where you can't, how you say, function.
So you will constantly be
medicating yourself, you know,
meaning using to run
from the shame or to hide from the shame.
And like I said, these drugs
are not what they used to be.
So instead of it altering your
mind, the shit stays there.
And then it's there even more.
And it's like, not only
are you feeling shame,
you're feeling guilty because
you're constantly smoking
or medicating yourself.
And you're not trying to do
anything about the shame.
So it's like hopeless sits
in, self worthlessness.
And then it all that can
either turn into anger
or it can give you a nervous breakdown.
And that's if you have a conscience.
You reap what you sew out here.
You think you're untouchable.
You think that you're all that,
you think you're big and bad.
Well, guess what?
When karma comes, no size, no skills.
Karma don't give a fuck
about none of that.
She's coming and she's
coming harder than you think.
And you know, it's like,
I prefer karma as a woman
for the simple fact,
she's just like a bitch
when she comes and she's
coming for that ass.
And she wants everybody to know
that you are reaping karma,
meaning that she is here.
She is present, that you
are reaping what you sow.
And it could be what you
thought was something so small
to something to,
it could be something you did
to somebody that you thought was no one.
Well, when karma comes,
she comes like you fucked
with her child or something,
you know?
And it took her a while
to catch up to you.
But guess what?
She caught up to you
and she's gonna break you down
and she's got to make you
realize that, hey, look,
this is karma.
I'm the one from all
the shit that you did.
And you thought you got away with it.
Well, here I am, tough guy,
bad ass or untouchable.
Now, what are you going to do?
So when she's done with you,
she can either leave you
speechless, meaning dead
or she can give you something
a lot of time to think about,
meaning you could wind up
in prison for two, maybe,
not just the, the average life sentence
but maybe the two life
sentence, because it's like,
depending on what you've done
and depending on your past,
your past is gonna come
and meet up with karma.
And I'm going to tag team that ass
and it's going to run concurrent
and you're going to be
through his money basically.
She is no joke.
She is for real, I can't
say I've dealt with her,
but I've seen her in action.
And she, like, I'm telling you,
she is nothing to play with.
I advise you to keep it one hundred,
be true to thyself
and you'll be all right, all
that thinking you're going
to make a quick come up
and it doesn't matter.
And that person doesn't
matter what you're doing.
Doesn't matter if it's not true.
If there's, you're not getting your money
or your hustle not real,
I advise you not to do it
because karma is in the
midst of all of that.
Yeah.
That's some for real shit.
This shit right here and now mark.
Woo.
It's crazy, man.
It's, man, it's not funny anymore.
And that's oh my dear momma.
This shit is not fun.
- [Cameraman] You're time to get out.
- Yep.
- [Cameraman] All right, thank you.
- [Woman 1] Yeah, it is time to get out.